welcome back to New rockstars and holy
moly is that dang spot holy like what
the hell is up with that anyway like how
do the spot's Powers work and across the
spiderverse and how to have spots Powers
works in the Marvel Comics of the past
well lucky for you two experts in how to
control your holes are here right in
front of you in the form of myself and
the lovely Whitney van Lennon what's
going on with me oh yeah man we are
experts on holes so tune in oh yeah
I didn't do those four years of college
for nothing you know what I'm saying
nothing
the holes of a person
nothing on what a weird name but yeah
I'm gonna be hitting you guys with the
facts about movie spot first and then
Whitney's gonna take over with the
breakdown of all things comic book spots
because she is the comic book Maestro
over here Teamwork Makes the DreamWork
across the spider versus all about
teamwork so like that's why we're doing
this man like I'm miles you are Gwen
that's 200 miles and I can be Gwen no
absolutely I mean whatever you want dude
either way is very cool with me they're
both very cool people all right gang
let's talk about spot from across the
spider verse because this dude has a
chaotic really dark power set because as
we learned in the movie spot used to be
a scientist at alcamax named Jonathan on
who works closely with one Olivia
Octavius to complete kingpin's
multi-dimensional super collider and it
looks like the role that Liv gave
Jonathan in the super collider project
involved him discovering the mysteries
of this strange black goo in a jar but
what is this black goo well every time
the Super collider is turned on in both
movies a weird blob of Dark Matter
starts to grow in the middle and this
blob of dark matter is the very portal
to the spider-verse that Kingpin and Doc
Ock wanted to open it in order to find
variants of kingpin's family across the
Multiverse and we first see this dark
matter portal in action when the Green
Goblin of Earth 1610 shoves Chris Pine
Peter Parker's head into the portal and
he gets a face-to-face view with the
webs of the spider-verse itself all
while the super collider locks in onto
Peter Parker's spider DNA and then
brings spiderwin spider hand and the
rest of the spider gang to miles's
Universe however when the super collider
exploded at the end of introduce
spider-verse a container with a sample
of a dark matter portal cracked open
releasing all that dark matter onto
Jonathan's body dramatically
transforming him into the chaotic being
known as the spot looking like a whole
cow mostly because those dark matter
spots appear to have drastically
corrupted Jonathan's mind and Amplified
his negative emotions you know very much
feeding off of Jonathan's negative
emotional state kind of like Spider-Man
with the Venom symbiote or one of the
maximoff with the dark hold the power of
Darkness seems to have that effect
across all of Marvel media but another
side effect the power of Darkness also
tends to make wielder's experience is an
overwhelming sense of emptiness and
emptiness spot tells miles that he's
trying to fill with more holes I think
that's a lesson for everybody don't feel
your absiness with more holes okay just
get a get a therapist you don't need
more holes
inside of a hole that's not how holes
exactly it's just it's just it's a hole
and you gotta fix it you either gotta
fix it or you die because otherwise it's
too many holes yeah you you don't feel a
hole with more holes okay let's just
make more hole remember that we said
this right just put it on a shirt Wanda
actually opens up about how her dark
chaos powers influence her emotions to
everyone's favorite boner in one
division because she experienced a very
similar sense of emptiness I only
remember feeling
completely alone just endless
nothingness but anyways because of the
emotional sensitivity of spots Powers
his Dark Matter portals are extremely
responsive to his fear and also his
anger and we see this exemplified best
when he first comes across Miles Morales
during his incredibly daring ATM Heist
at the start of the movie Spiderman and
then later when spot tells miles how
they created each other at the ruins of
kingpin's collider he actually got so
angry that he lost all of his Dark
Matter spots which causes him to build a
mini super collider just so he can
collect more Dark Matter spots to become
the ultimate Nemesis for Miles Morales
however it appears that the more dark
matter he absorbs the more mentally
unstable and completely unreasonable
spot becomes which now makes spot an
unhinged massive multiversal threat of
Darkness much like Wanda was in
Multiverse of Madness but that's just
movie spot what about the original spot
from the comics with me oh man about
that we gotta talk about the spot from
the comics because he has a completely
different origin story than what we see
in across the spider verse in six one 6
Dr Jonathan's on life isn't forever
changed because he gets bopped in the
Noggin by a bagel but in fact he kinda
sort of did this to himself back in 1982
Spectacular Spider-Man Vol 1 issue
number 98 Dr Ahn was a scientist working
in kingpin's laboratory attempting to
artificially mimic the Vigilante cloak's
dark dimensional powers in hopes that it
might heal Wilson fisk's wife Vanessa
his goal was to reproduce cloaks
extremely high radiation level to then
ultimately replicate his exact Powers
although he succeeded in matching the
levels of radiation his equipment caused
a city-wide power outage and the
wavelength of the radiation produced was
altered a large black circular portal
appeared in the lab and Dr Johnny
realizes that he may never get another
chance to explore the scientific
reaction you know that saying curiosity
killed the cat here it's more like
curiosity made the scientists climb into
an alternate Dimension and permanently
altered his abilities in appearance
I know how that is I know how that be
you know how that is you know when
sometimes you're just like gotta see
what's in this hole and then you go and
then you completely change everything
about who you are as a man ugh man if I
had a nickel for every time that
happened to me STDs am I right anyways
after climbing through the spot portal
Dr Johnny wakes up in a black and white
polka dot Dimension and assumes that he
must be inside of cloak's dark dimension
he quickly realizes however that his
experiment plus the blackout opened a
portal to A Realm of Darkness and Light
the inside of the in-between Dimension
has a weightless atmosphere and Dr
Anna's The Duel swimmies to propel
himself towards a familiar looking
portal he's just going like this and
he's like oh I'll get there someday I
believe in myself interestingly he can
recognize the difference between his
different portals instantly allowing him
to remerge in 616. unlike the version of
the spot in atsv the comic book version
Embraces his new identity almost
immediately when he pops back into his
own reality looking like a freakish
Dalmatian he plays around with his new
spots like they're a brand new Lego set
on Christmas morning he doesn't waste
any time being bummed out about losing
his face he gets right to work thinking
about how he can use them to defeat any
superhero in any part of the Multiverse
specifically he decides to focus on
Spider-Man Matthew you to a bagel Grudge
but because he knows how powerful our
stickiest hero is fun fact fun fact in
the comics Dr Jonathan on changes his
name to the spot because it's a pun on
the phrase Johnny on the spot which
means a readily available person which
is a very fitting name dude it's a
fitting name because he has hundreds of
spots like on the ready that he can just
be like I'm Johnny I'm a spot I'm Johnny
on the spot and I'm throwing my spots
and there's gonna be spots inside and
holes in my holes that's how that's how
you be holes inside of holes that's the
Johnny on way the the Johnny on way
holes on holes
and look guys Father's Day is coming up
fast and if you want to get your father
a gift that he'll use every day you
should check out ridge ridge has
reinvented the wallet and it's a massive
improvement over the bulky dad wallets
of yesteryear the ridge wallet is slim
but expands to hold up to 12 cards plus
cash Ridge wallets come in over 30
colors and styles including carbon fiber
burnt titanium forged Ember and burnt
Damascus plus these wallets are designed
with the 21st century in mind each
wallet is built with RFID blocking
materials that protect your info from
digital pickpockets and has an optional
air tag attachment so you'll never lose
your wallet again find the best Father's
Day gift by going to ridge.com new
rockstars right now and you can save up
to 40 through June 15th that is
ridge.com new rockstars we thank Rich
for sponsoring this video and for
protecting my money while playing around
with his new personal portals the spot
discovers that he can remove spots from
his body suspend them midair and even
change their shapes and sizes in future
Comics he even finds a way to form
portals into solid orbs for him to perch
on mid-battle like a little cat he's
like a little cat on the the head of a
chair and it's real sweet I love it most
importantly he learns that he can step
into one spot and emerge instantly from
another even if his exit is in a
different reality than his point of
entry knowing how powerful his holes are
he decides to hide his abilities from
Kingpin which is generally a smart thing
to do if you have any abilities don't
tell Kingpin always Hydra holds from
Kingpin don't show Kingpin your holes if
bad things happen
this thought strategically places his
portals around town giving him the
element of surprise in future fights but
when he finally meets Spider-Man our
favorite webbed hero just makes fun of
him exactly like miles does an atsv
Peter Parker also just kind of thinks
he's like a big loser I love how
Spider-Man just like a little bully and
like spot calls him out on this it's
because he was a nerd who got bullied
and now that he has cool powers and abs
he's like well I guess I'm just gonna
bully this scientist right he's like
like spot is like yo you forgot where
you came from man let's be nerds
together together why are you doing this
let's let's just let's just be friends
but the spot's lack of physical strength
doesn't hold him back at all in his
early days when the ability to sneak
attack anyone by popping in and out of
the polka dot Dimension it will he can
dodge disappear and reappear so quickly
that Spider-Man and other Heroes can't
get him to stay in one place long enough
to Counter-Strike spider is definitely a
lot more intimidated by him once the
spot drags him into the image between
realm and forces him out of a different
portal than the one that he entered he
can technically pull anyone into the
dimension with him rather add his Mercy
to find the right Escape Route in future
Comics The Spot grows much stronger with
experience even besting Jessica Jones
and Captain Marvel at one point in his
villain career I didn't know that you
could get the jump on Carol Danvers but
he gets the jump on Carol Dan that is
banana he just pops her in the nose
right in the kisser right in the right
in the little snoot his Now You See Me
Now you don't tricks are especially
effective when he's fighting multiple
opponents because he can easily use his
spots to punch his advertaries through
space and time not only has he taken on
an entire room of Assassins at once he
even reached through a portal and sliced
Bucky's vibranian arm cleaned off of his
body he's straight up he went into a
portal Bucky's arm is there and he's
just like
and like gets them damn that's that's
crazy and you would think that his
ability to steal prosthetic limbs would
make Rocket Raccoon his best friend but
no rocket actually just likes to mess
with him by firing a gun at one of his
spots and then watching all the bullets
spray out of his other spot so you just
see he's like he's like
that's hilarious just like what happens
if I do this and I'm like oh you silly
silly little furry man I love you this
is why we don't give raccoons guns
when the spot realizes that Kingpin is
about to discover a secret identity he
quickly figures out how to hide his
bizarre new appearance he concentrates
on consolidating all of his spots into
one large spot on his tummy this means
that Dr on can still look totally normal
whenever he wants to unlike the spot
from across the spider first he can even
group several spots in one place
reducing the amount of white space on
his body which makes it harder for any
hero to land a single blow wow so
blackface interesting spot is canceled
I'm telling you I'm announcing it right
now spot is canceled I saw that black
face in the movie I see you spot you
can't when Spider-Man's fist collides
with the back of spot's head it simply
disappears into one of his portals
without even hurting him at all
combining his holes to form bigger
portals becomes one of his go-to
Maneuvers when it comes to dodging
attacks when Spider-Man tries to capture
him with a web net the spot simply forms
a portal large enough to just swallow
the webs we've also seen Spy use his
portal that vacuum stuck his opponents
into the polka dot Dimension out of thin
air after being experimented on by the
coyote the spot gains the ability to
grow multiple Limbs and Sprout them from
his various portals nightmare fuel great
it's nightmare fuel 100 the thing that I
find the most fascinating about the spot
is his inability to stay dead this dude
has been murdered at least three times
and somehow he always manages to come
back to life off page first his neck is
snapped by Tombstone but he's later
resurrected by the hand unfortunately
Wolverine stabs him through the gut like
five minutes into his mission somehow
he's brought back once again and joins
modoc's villain supergroup although he
was definitely the least popular member
by far when he tries to double cross
modok the Mandarin accepts his offerings
then locks him inside his own polka dot
Dimension like most of us did during the
pandemic the spot goes absolutely
batshit Stir Crazy from being alone for
so long and starts concentrating on his
Escape at first he's only able to
project faint images of himself into 616
but eventually breaks through to the
other side by focusing on reuniting with
his son Wyatt most recently in issue
number three of 2022's Carnage volume 3
Carnage completely dismembered and
beheaded the spot ripping his limbs
apart like tissue paper just like arm
here leg here just totally he doesn't
need those he just rips down rips him
mouth to butthole just everything gone
no your head no more anything but even
with his head disconnected from his body
he vows that he'll eventually return to
life using the spotted Dimension he's
currently dead in the comics but with
the characters Resurgence in the Sony
spider-verse my guess is little comeback
to life like we're all soon but that's
that solves the spot's Powers that's all
spots powers in the comics those were
all his powers in the movies
but like I really hope that we see like
all these like weird freakish freakish
like powerful version of the spot in the
sequel because dude seriously I feel
like we we're gonna see some crazy
at a spot once he like gains his
confidence he's kind of Unstoppable and
that's like the one thing that his Comic
version has is like the confidence to be
like yeah Kingpin I'm gonna go do my own
thing I'm gonna form my own super
villain and I'm gonna go to a
different reality and get away from my
boss oh but yes thank you guys so much
for watching this video you guys are
amazing thank you to the wonderful
Whitney van Lanigan for her amazing
um comic book information on the spot
follow her at Whitney puppy you can
follow me at Mass retainment but most
importantly you can follow the rock
stars wherever we are on the internet
especially here on YouTube and subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis and
everything that you love thanks so much
for watching we'll see you guys later
goodbye bye
foreign
[Music]